[Music]
hi my name is Denise Chavez and I'm the
chair for an electoral arrow then she
led us a very traditional dish from
Puebla nobody goes to Puebla without
eating enchiladas
Oh Molly poblano the enchiladas you can
need everywhere in Puebla and every day
by the Molly poblano wood chicken or
with pork is just a special occasions
like birthdays when people get married
every restaurant original Mexican food
when you go in there it's not original
food so over here I tried I push myself
to don't forget my culture over here we
use in a special tortillas I get it blue
corn from Mexico and we cook the corn
and then we put it in the Molino and we
make fresh tortillas fresh masa we use
in for tortillas to roll with chicken
but you had to put it inside to the
Molly to get with that's why we're
calling enchiladas they had to be very
wet you can use anything you want for
decoration for the garnish for original
traditional avocado cheese cream and
that's it the Molly poblano it's very
traditional but also it's difficult to
do these recipes from my grandma I use
in more than six chilies one of the
chili we call him ancho it's like more
red mulatto is black and then procedure
passage is sweet if you want more spicy
you can use chile Morita Chipotle or
pooja I use in raisins cinnamon garlic
cloves black pepper a nice implant end
all that ingredients they give you a
nice flavor with with the children it's
very hard to do the morning that is very
good
I tried to do everything
traditional 100 when I go to Mexico
I always behind my sister or my mom they
cook everything like from scratch and
they still doing the least a mile they
must fresh fresh tortillas so it's many
many dishes that I can still bring in I
love to do that to bring from my culture
original place and show the real Mexican
food
[Music]